deux femmes de 95 et 93 ans sont
décédées après avoir été violé par un
homme à Argenteuil ça s'est passé au
sein du service de gériatrie de
l'hôpital Victor du puis le suspect
Samir B a été interpellé par les
policiers et placé en garde à vue samedi
14 octobre totalement extérieur à
l'établissement Samir B a été intercepté
aux alentours de 16h30 par le service de
sécurité de l'hôpital alors qu'il
sortait de la chambre d'une femme de 93
ans atteinte de troubl psychologique et
en état de démence du sperme a été
retrouvé sur les draps du lit de la
victime et plus tard dans la soirée la
femme de 93 ans a été Pr d'un malaise et
a perdu connaissance mais le personnel
soignant n'a pas réussi à la réanimer
après un arrêt cardiaque sa mort fait
l'objet d'une deuxième enquête presque
au même moment une autre femme de 95 ans
avait alerté les soignants en expliquant
que ce même individu s'était introduit
dans sa chambre quelques minutes plus
tôt selon son témoignage le suspect lui
a fait subir des attouchements sexuels
et une pénétration digitale ce qui
relève juridiquement d'un viol ce lundi
23 octobre nous avons appris que la
deuxème nonagénner est décédé 4 jours
après les fait selon nos informations
samirbe a reconnu les fait lors de son
transport au commissaire l'individu
était connu au fichier de traitement
d'antécédents judiciire pour agression
sexuelle pourtant il a été laissé libre
dans l'attente de son procès qui doit se
tenir le 16 novembre prochain le parquet
a annoncé faire appel de cette décision
de le laisser en liberté provisoire
décision qui a aussi surpris certains
[Musique]
policiers